FEMALE SPEAKER: Thanks
everyone for coming.
I'm just going to introduce
Ruth here.
I've personally been connected
with AJWS, the American Jewish
World Service, for a
number of years.
I did a volunteer trip in El
Salvador with them many years
ago, helping post-earthquake
relief reconstruction.
That's one of the many, many
projects that AJWS organizes.
And so I was thrilled when I was
contacted by AJWS telling
me that Ruth wanted to come and
speak with us about many
of the more recent projects
they've been involved with.
So today we're mostly talking
about their work in India, as
you've all seen an invite.
I'll just give it to Ruth.
RUTH MESSINGER: Thank you.
I am delighted both for all you
here in the room and for
all of you that are on remote.
It's a really wonderful
opportunity for me to be able
to talk with a lot of you.
I'm Ruth Messinger.
I have the privilege
of running American
Jewish World Service.
And I'm based in New York, but
Laura Thomas is the executive
director in the San Francisco
office and Spencer Katz is on
the staff in the San
Francisco office.
So we are here as well.
We're going to just--
feel free to look at the slides
at any point that you
might want.
I'm not talking to them
specifically, but it's just a
loop of photographs that show
both some of our work around
the world on site in various
communities and the grassroots
activists that we support.
And also, I think there's some
pictures of the advocacy that
we do in this country targeted
to members of Congress to get
them to change policies.
I want to give you an
introduction to American
Jewish World Service generally,
and then talk, as
Anya promised, about
our work in India.
Let me just start with
one Indian story.
And we'll come back to
that at the end.
This is about a woman
named Zinat.
Zinat, when she was 17 years
old, had already been divorced
three times, all from
managers that were
made against her will.
She was first married right
after puberty, which I'm sorry
to tell you is sometimes late,
to a man who abused her.
And then she was abused in her
two subsequent marriages.
She had never been
to a doctor.
And she didn't know-- and this
is really quite common for us
around the world--
that actually she lives in a
country, in this case India,
in which there's a good law.
So there's a law in India, the
Protection of Women from
Domestic Violence Act.
It was passed in 2005.
And that law should have
protected her from the abuse,
but obviously if she doesn't
know about it, the cultural
practices don't change
that quickly.
So what happened was that Zinat
came to the office of
one of our grantee organizations
that's called
the Shaheen Resource
Centre for Women.
And it works in Hyderabad
in the old city.
And it's targeted specifically
to help Muslim women-- so this
is a large Muslim population
in a Hindu country--
and Dalit women.
Dalit is the current name for
the lowest caste which used to
be called the untouchables.
Some of you obviously
know this.
So Shaheen with Muslim and Dalit
women and girls against
gender discrimination and
gender-based violence.
They helped her negotiate an
agreement with her parents
that recognized her legal right
to be protected from
both domestic violence
and forced marriage.
They referred her to a doctor
who checked for pregnancy and
sexually transmitted diseases.
And most importantly, of course,
they provided her with
vocational training that
allowed her to become
financially independent, less
likely to fall victim to the
same situation again.
And now she's in a position,
which is where Shaheen is
trying to get many women, that
she both has an economic
independence and if at any point
she chooses or wants to
marry again, she has the
support of her family.
She knows she has the ability
to leave an abusive marriage
if she chooses.
She knows what her rights are.
And she knows how to
access services.
So that's like a capsule
story of what we're
doing around the world.
We are an American-based
non-governmental organization
that describes ourselves as
being inspired by the Jewish
commitment to pursue justice,
but working to realize human
rights and to end poverty for
the most marginalized people
in the developing world.
We support a large number, 550
small, usually grassroots
social justice organizations
in Africa, Asia, and the
Americas, targeted
to 19 countries.
They particularly affect the
lives of women and girls,
migrants and refugees, and
the LGBTI population.
And the thematic areas in which
they work are to promote
recovery from conflict and
disasters; to defend access to
food, land, and livelihoods,
so agricultural
sustainability; and to advance
the rights of women and girls,
which is what we were
talking about.
The way we think about our work
is that we are supporting
rights that people by and large
in this country take for
granted, the right to education,
the right to health
care, the right to be free to
speak our minds, the right to
vote in elections, the right
to love whom we choose, and
frankly the right to live, we
hope, without violence and
rape and discrimination, and
then very importantly, from
the livelihoods point of view,
the right for people to till
their own land.
Those rights are, as I said
before, not recognized in many
of these countries, or sadly
they're recognized in print
but they're not recognized
in reality.
And what we do and what we are
really good at is finding
these grassroots partners.
So I want to sort of take a
moment and clarify for you,
because many of you know very,
very good international relief
and development organizations.
We do do some relief work.
And I'll talk about
that briefly.
But we are a distinguished from
almost any other western
or American organization that
you might know of that works
in the developing world
because we don't
send western staff.
So we can find a group, we can
sometimes find a group that
starts with a grant literally
of $2,000 or $3,000.
Our average gift over
many, many years is
around $30,000 a year.
And that is an amount
of money--
invested in local people who
have their own vision of
justice and are doing their own
work, that's an amount of
money to change the lives of a
community in many very, very
dramatic ways.
And sometimes our organizations
grow to a point
where they're highly visible,
they're known
in the public world.
We were the first funder of
Leymah Gbowee, the Liberian
woman who won the Nobel Peace
Prize two years ago for the
works that she did to bring
peace to Liberia.
But to be honest with you, most
of our organizations are
not going to win the
Nobel Peace Prize.
But they are advancing and
changing the status for people
who live in some of the most
difficult parts of the world.
So I do want to talk
about India.
But I want to just say
two other things
about our work in general.
We take monitoring
and evaluation of
our work very seriously.
So we hold our project partners,
our very grassroots
partners, accountable for
the work they do.
And we stay with them
for a long time.
And while that is the core of
our work, the grant-making
work we do overseas, we also
work in this country.
And in this country we meet
with groups like you.
We work with people who will
help us on some key advocacy
issues, because there are areas
in which if the United
States would change its policy
and practice, things would be
vastly different not just for
the 550 groups that we work
with, but for people
all over the world.
And the most current example
of that is actually in the
President's budget.
In the budget that the White
House announced two days ago
is a provision to move food
aid money out of the
Department of Agriculture, where
by law, by law, it has
to be used to buy American
food and ship it tens of
thousands of miles away, which
takes longer, costs much more,
and undermines local farmers.
And so in the budget, 45% of
the food aid money going
forward, if Congress passes the
budget, would be able to
be used flexibly for local
procurement of food, which is
a huge change in-- its a better,
more efficient use of
our tax dollars, but it's also
a huge investment in
agricultural sustainability
around the world.
So some of you know about us
from our disaster work.
We did substantial work against
the genocide in Darfur
and continue to work on
peace issues in Sudan.
We came to many people's
attention after the 2004
tsunami in South Asia and
more recently after the
earthquake in Haiti.
And I'm happy to go back and
talk about any of that work
later when you get a chance
to ask questions.
But I want to concentrate
on our work in India.
So in some ways right now, of
course, India is in the
spotlight because of the
horrific rape in Delhi and the
story about the woman who
was raped and died.
But I suspect, given who you
are and given the wonderful
place that we're meeting, that
a lot of you sort of think
about India in the terms in
which the United States and
the United States economic pages
talk about India these
days, which is as a hugely
populous country with rapid
development and a great deal
of money being made and
invested in-country and a great
deal of new technology
and new capacity.
And the problem is that, of
course, all of that is true.
But it's also a country with an
ever-widening gap between
its rich and it's poor.
So at the same time as you
read-- and you might have seen
some of these stories about
people who are building
buildings that even in America
would be considered like a
condominium construct for
10 families with 10 huge
floor-through apartments, it's
owned by one person.
He hasn't decided yet whether or
not to move in, but he has,
I think, it's a 10-, maybe it's
a 12-story building for
himself and his family.
So there are those
the excesses.
But meanwhile there are sort of
two huge problems in this
country that we've chosen to
devote our attention to.
One is that some of the efforts
to make money, both to
develop new areas of cities
and more importantly to
develop new opportunities for
mining, are displacing people
from their land.
So I've actually been in a
semi-urban community in Delhi,
which is the home where tens
of thousands of people who
used to live in a slum in Delhi
were simply told, you're
being relocated.
And not only are they losing
their homes and therefore
losing a sense of community, but
these were all people who
had some sort of job that they
could make their way to.
And they've now been displaced
to a place on the outskirts of
the city where the only job for
them is garbage pickers.
So they go out on the road
and they collect garbage.
And they bring the garbage into
this rural development
area and they sort through it,
looking for valuables.
And when I was there two years
ago, they were at risk of
losing that one single economic
opportunity because
it was becoming commercialized.
So there were now new trucks
that were going to be picking
up garbage and-- whatever you
do with garbage, chewing it
all up, but not allowing people
to sort through it.
And that might sound to all of
us like a great technological
advance, except it means that
this whole community of
thousands of people that were
displaced from their homes in
the city will now have nothing
to sustain themselves and no
way to get to any job that
might be available.
So the displacement of the
poorest both urban and rural
people from their land and
homes due to development,
industry, and mining
is one big problem.
And then the second problem,
which I've referenced already,
is the pervasive discrimination
and violence
that's perpetrated against women
and girls, against the
LGBTI population, and against
the sex worker population.
And you will remind me later
on, be sure I say something
about sex workers
particularly.
So here's an example of the
kind of work that we do.
In Mumbai specifically, where
there is, as I said throughout
the country, there's a Muslim
population, life is
particularly difficult
for Muslim women.
Their traditional gender
roles don't allow
them to go to school.
It deprives them of status
in their households.
They are forced into early
marriage, many of them in
their teens and some of them
younger than that.
You might have seen-- this
wasn't India, it was
Afghanistan.
But there was a story in The New
York Times two weeks ago
about a father who sold his
six-year-old daughter into
marriage as the only way to get
some money for the family
that was like in desperate
straits.
International statistics show
that adolescent brides are
much more likely to be abused.
They're isolated from
their communities.
And as I said before, they
don't have any idea that
there's a law that would
protect them.
So there's a group we
support in Mumbai.
It's called Aawaaz-e-Niswaan.
It's a group that works in the
Muslim community to educate
girls and to teach them what
their rights are under the
law, to teach them how to defend
those rights, to teach
them the dangers of early
marriage and early
childbearing from a health point
of view and from the
point of view of interrupting
their education and their
economic growth potential.
Girls are taught everything from
self-defense skills to
ways to become peer educators.
They're taught how to
express their rights
against arranged marriages.
And they're given some skills
for financial independence.
And they're given vocational
training, access to college
scholarships, and assistance
in finding jobs.
And I think one of the strengths
of this group and
one of the reasons why I thought
to include them in
this presentation is they
represent what American Jewish
World Service is all about.
They see the problem.
They figured out the solution.
And they saw that the solution
couldn't just be
uni-dimensional.
It's not just stay in school.
It's not just tell people what
the law is and try to get them
legal defenders.
It's like you have to work on
this issue on a variety of
different levels at once.
And from our point of
view, ideally we'll
do that with groups.
But we'll also hope that some
of the groups that we are
supporting we'll be preferencing
education, peer
education, and empowerment.
Some of them will be emphasizing
teaching young
women some degree of financial
literacy and financial
independence, since that turns
out to be one of the things
they need in order to be able
to stand their ground.
And it for sure involves
teaching
basic leadership skills.
So working on all of these
different fronts, we see that
the alumni, the graduates of
Aawaaz-e-Niswaan are really
key leaders now in
their community.
And they are joining in the
effort that you may have read
about in India recently of women
standing up and saying,
we have to end this essentially
right to rape
which is so prevalent
in our society.
So in December the staff and the
alumni of Aawaaz-e-Niswaan
was significantly involved in
organizing around the country
against rape and for
a violence-free
environment for women.
And make no mistake about
it, this change
will occur very slowly.
But we're able with each of
these groups that we fund to
help them evaluate what they're
doing and then to help
them work with each other to
evaluate any success in moving
the needle on the broad
questions of human rights and
governance in-country.
And about India specifically,
I would say it's
sort of for me a mix.
The good news is that it's a
comparatively, comparatively
given where we work, stable
democracy that does have laws
on the books.
And the challenge right now is
that not only people don't
know those laws, but that people
in this country think
that India has solved
all its problems.
And that's to all people who
visit, stay in five-star
hotels, they think that there
seem to be a lot of poor
people in the streets but that's
not really the story.
A lot of people know that that's
where their call center
is and that everything
must be fine.
So it's a country that's in
a sense at risk of being
redefined as a developed world
country when that is
just not its story.
OK, I wanted to just say a
little bit about sex work,
because I'd like to see
if I could possibly be
controversial before we
turn to questions.
So we work with an organization,
a couple of
organizations in
India and other
organizations around the world.
And we differ from many people
you know in that we make a
distinction between trafficking
and sex work.
And that distinction
is not common.
And sometimes it's commonly
understood that there's a
difference, but people
see them the same.
So I just want to say that we
work against trafficking.
We work against child soldiers
in Uganda and Ghana.
We work against child
slaves in the
fishing industry in Ghana.
We work against trafficked
women all over.
But there are women in this
world, including in India, who
have chosen sex work as the best
way for them to make a
living and support
their families.
They're not owned by pimps.
They are not the trafficked
women who are
moved across borders.
They have decided that that is
the way to create an income
for themselves.
It's not the choice that you
would make or you would make
or I would make.
But we do believe in serious
empowerment by people of their
own futures.
And these women organize and get
funding from us to protect
their own health, to stop
themselves from being abused
by the local police, and to be
sure that nobody comes in, as
it were, to sort
of buy them up.
But they have chosen to do
sex work as a profession.
And we are part of a small
network of funding
organizations around the world
called the Red Umbrella Fund
which supports women who are sex
workers by choice and not
trafficked women.
So one of the groups we
support in India is an
organization called Sangram,
which works specifically on
behalf of sex workers in India
in order to basically, as I
said, insist that their clients
use condoms, provide
access to health care, and get
protection from the police if
they are raped as opposed to
actually selling their
services to somebody.
So that's a very quick snapshot
of work we do in
India, which is actually
paralleled by work we do all
over the world.
India is the country
for us with our
largest number of grantees.
Of course, that's partly
because of its size.
But it also means that it
offers us a significant
opportunity for these groups to
be working with each other,
for these groups to be
collaborating and learning
those organizing, mobilizing
advocacy techniques that will
help them make change
countrywide, which is our
vision, with them.
It's their vision and therefore
is our vision for
their future.
So that's the story, starting
with Zinat and ending with two
or three organizations that
I hope give you a
flavor of what we do.
But I would love to take
your questions and
challenges about anything.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Googlers like to think
of themselves as being
data-driven.
And a lot of people give their
money to organizations
recommended by GiveWell,
for example.
I was interested you're
mentioning holding grantees
accountable, doing
evaluations.
Could you please say
more about that?
RUTH MESSINGER: Sure.
First of all, we have very high
ratings, highest ratings
from the American Institute
of Philanthropy, Charity
Navigator, and the Better
Business Bureau.
And we pride ourselves
on that.
Second of all, we've grown
a lot in the last--
we're 28 years old.
Most of our growth has been
in the last 14 years.
And I say that to say we've gone
from being a $2.8 million
organization to a $51 million
organization.
And in the process, we have been
thinking and rethinking
our approach to monitoring
and evaluation.
So we've always done monitoring
and evaluation for
an individual grantee.
And we basically have done it,
and quite successfully, I want
to say, by asking a grass roots
organization that we
were thinking of funding, for
them to tell us what would
they do with, fill in the blank,
$15,000, helping them
list the goals, usually helping
them take away half
the goals, because they are much
more certain that they
can do more than they could
possibly do, and attaching
metrics to some of them.
And then we've evaluated that
on an ongoing basis.
We are the kind of evaluators
that say, we really, really
want the truth.
We have grants officers in
our New York office.
We have in-country
consultants.
We want you to really tell us
when you're being successful
and when you're not, because we
are not going to take away
your money at the first
opportunity.
We're interested in if something
isn't working, why
is it not working?
That was the structure for
evaluation that we used for
the first 10 years
that I was there.
For the last four years, we've
invested much more heavily in
just exactly what you're asking
about, looking for the
most useful kind of independent
data, teaching
monitoring and evaluation,
trying to help groups use the
data that they collect for us
in a feedback loop to figure
out what they need to be doing
differently to improve the
numbers or decrease
the numbers.
And now we have to set up a
department of strategic
learning, research,
and evaluation.
And they will work both on
monitoring and evaluating our
in-country work-- so how
successful are we in
Washington, what happens with
the President's budget , how
many members of Congress votes
do we actually change?--
to also adding a new overlay of
work on our international
grant-making, particularly where
I described, like are we
moving the needle on a human
rights issue outside of just
the work we're doing with the
particular organization?
In India, in Kenya, five years
from now will it be evident
that many more people know what
their rights are under
these supposedly good laws on
the books against gender-based
violence and how will
they do that?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I personally know of
many small organizations in
India that work to improve
the status of women, of
impoverished people.
How do you go and partner with
an organization, because I
know of so many.
And they're all doing small
things in small
parts of the country.
It's a huge country.
RUTH MESSINGER: So it's a
perfect question, because our
notion is both to find those
small groups, pick the best,
but then grow them into a larger
movement, because as
you said, you can have some
great small groups scattered
around, sometimes their problem
is just a lack of
consistency of resources.
So they have a great plan, but
as you all know, if you spend
all your life looking for money,
you don't have much
time to do your program.
So first of all, how we find
the organizations is we are
getting better and better known
in the countries where
we work as the go-to place for
grassroots groups that have a
vision of change.
Second of all, I described
us as a human rights
organization.
Our staff, our in-country
consultants who help us find
and monitor projects and our
program officers, take this
notion of human rights
very seriously.
But I just want to
be clear to you.
It doesn't mean that some little
grassroots group that
like wants to bring girls
together has to say, we have a
right to education and we have
the Universal Declaration.
It's the way in which people
talk about it.
It's like we're doing a lot.
We are actually the eighth
largest funder of LGBTI work
period, in the world, which is
wonderful for us and really
embarrassing for the world.
But it's how do those people
talk about their human rights?
They have made in some cases
unbelievably brave decisions
to come out of the closet,
to find each other, to be
challenging laws that
are pretty serious.
And they basically, when you
listen to them, they say look,
we just did this secretly
as long as we could.
But we have a right too.
So it's the use of
that language.
It's that sensitivity.
And the reason for that is
because those groups are more
sustainable.
If you're sort of a-- and I
don't want to criticize this,
but if you're sort of an
organization that does work
when somebody funds you, that's
less reliable for long
term social change in the world
than if you just say, we
have a right to this.
And when Leymah Gbowee,
the woman I
referenced from Liberia--
her success was in organizing
women to end the war, end the
civil war in Liberia, and demand
the peace process,
which she did by, among
other things, the
women went on sex strikes.
So if you think that only
happens in ancient Greece, you
need to brush up on your recent
Liberian history.
But when she did that, frankly
at the end of that time she
was like a hero.
And she had five children.
And people said, OK, you've done
wonders for our country,
go back and take care
of your children.
And she was like outraged.
She was like, what are
you talking about?
I just proved that you can bring
together Muslim women
and Christian women.
You can make women stand up
to and control the idiotic
behavior of men-- that's the
way she talks about it.
And I want to go and teach the
girls in this country and in
neighboring countries how
to assert their rights.
And we were the only people
who would fund here.
Everybody else was like, you
did a great job, go home.
And what my staff said was, this
is a woman who's going to
set the world on fire.
And we need to support
her efforts.
So I think there's that.
And then I think the benefit
for us now of focusing and
deepening our work in these 19
countries will be precisely,
and let's take India as an
example, to bring these
different groups together.
And one of the things that
happens when you bring
together groups that are working
on the same issue,
especially in a country as large
as India, they don't
know each other.
And so they have no idea that
someone is working on
something similar in
the next town.
And they have no idea that
somebody thinks the first
thing to do with girls is to
educate them about their human
rights and somebody else thinks
that the first thing to
do with girls is to educate
them about their bodies.
And these groups, we bring
them together.
And they are so empowered,
because they are the experts.
It's not like we brought
together 10 groups in Kenya to
hear from a Western expert about
the rights of girls.
It's like this group is talking
about what they do and
this group is talking about--
and they're like, you want us
to put on an hour-long program
talking about what we do?
And so that's the effort.
And then the next effort is,
including with probably lots
of the groups you're familiar
with, is to play ball with
some of the other international
funders and say,
what can we do within the
structure of what these women
want anyway or these
people want anyway?
What can we do to help build
larger movements?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: My question was
there's a lot of support-- how
do you address the culture
problems, thought?
Because I might know my rights,
but it's not easy--
to give an example, I
know growing up--
I'm from a very I guess
relatively modern family, but
I was always told good
girls get married
before the age of 20.
And I did.
And after a broken engagement,
because of dowry demands--
and I'm not one of the
girls you see there.
But I know my friends who have
been divorced have had
problems getting admission
to their girls in school.
So it's not that they don't know
their rights and know the
girls have a right
to education.
But because this is a divorced
mother, has enough financial
support, doesn't get admission
for her child in school, where
do they go?
Because they're aware
of their rights.
RUTH MESSINGER: OK.
So that's like a brilliant
question.
And I was hoping some of you had
some experience with this.
So I want to say this
is the area where we
tread the most carefully.
There's proven no value in
Westerners coming in and
saying, you have a
right to this.
You can do that.
Just sign up here and then
here's your future.
And it turns out to be a bad
future, because you dared to
exercise your rights.
But what we find is that
people are doing
this on their own.
So they're stepping forward.
So take the example you
said, yes, I think
that's a perfect example.
Some women are exercising their
rights because they know
their rights.
And then they're getting out
of bad marriages or excess
dowry demands or abusive
situations.
And then they have
no place to turn.
And what we find, though, is
that they're coming together
with each other.
They're saying this is a policy
that has to be changed.
And I want to be
really honest.
I see that, particularly from
the point of view of the
people in this room and in our
organization, change in these
areas comes slowly.
But all I know is it doesn't
come at all if Westerners come
in and say, oh, you should
just do this or
you should do that.
So I'll tell you our most
exciting story.
It's not yet in India on this
issue, although this is an
issue we hope to tackle there
very soon in a big way.
But we funded, starting 15 years
ago, an organization in
Senegal that was organizing--
at that point they were
organizing literacy
programs for women.
And then they were organizing,
by their own request, a
program for women to learn
about health care.
But in 1998, that turned into
one of the women in one of
those health care groups saying,
if health care is a
human right, then why do we
practice female genital
cutting, which has hurt many
of us, has destroyed the
health of our daughters,
and has
killed some of our children?
And they organized from
the ground up.
And I can't give you a story
like this every day, but there
are now 2,200 villages in
Senegal that have banned
female genital cutting.
There's a law on the books.
They're training people
in other countries.
They've gotten several imams
to support them, which is
critical to the kind of longer
term cultural change you're
talking about, imams who now
say, it is not true that this
is a requirement in the Quran,
which is what all of these
women believed.
So I wish it was faster
than that.
And I think your example
is perfect.
Women who exercise their rights
then run into new
stumbling blocks.
But we have, in a sense for me,
there's a benefit to sort
of following the lead of the
people on the ground.
So we're not telling them, if
you do this, all will be fine.
We are picking up with them
where they say, several women
here actually chose
to exercise their
rights under the law.
And now they can't get their
children into school.
So that's the next step.
And so how do you help us?
How do you help us organize to
kind of make that change?
And it's complicated for sure.
So you described
it eloquently.
But they set the next threshold
in and next
challenge and the
next horizon.
I'll just tell you a personal
story that I love.
Last time I was at
Aawaaz-e-Niswaan, the Muslim
group that I talked to you
about, they brought in about
20 young girls who were in
there, they were learning--
literally it was a class they
were learning to write poetry
about their lives.
But they were also being
educated about their rights.
And they were fascinated
to have all
these Westerners there.
So they asked some questions
about, is their domestic
violence in the West?
And then they asked, there were
two or three men in our
group, so they said, we've never
had a man come to hear
about what we're doing.
And then finally, this one young
woman puts up here hand.
And she says, I hear that in
the United States, it's
possible for people of the same
sex to love each other.
I mean, it was like probably the
guttiest question asked in
Mumbai in the last decade.
And so the person who was
talking from our group said,
yes, that is true.
And I suddenly realized that I
had a picture, a photograph in
my wallet of my daughter and
my daughter-in-law, who are
not the same race, with
their daughter.
And so I said to the
young woman, here.
You might want to
look at this.
This is a married couple.
And these women pass this
photograph around.
It was like in tatters by
the end of an hour.
So it's like that
kind of story.
It's very slow efforts
at cultural change.
And that will not make gay
marriage legal in the United
States, much less in
Mumbai tomorrow.
But it's progress.
AUDIENCE: So I think it's
building a little
bit on what you asked.
I think even if women know their
rights, I think it's
hard for them to stand up to
their brothers and their
fathers and all of this.
How much do you guys, or how
have you guys thought about
educating not just the women
but the parents and the
siblings and other people that
are willing to help?
RUTH MESSINGER: The answer
is absolutely.
And that's the kind of question
that we'll ask a
group that we're
about to fund.
OK, so it sounds like you really
have a determined plan
to sort of bring in girls
and do this and do that.
But we'll say, it's sort of like
the example I gave you,
we might say, we know of another
group where they're
trying to share this education
with men or with parents.
And it's a question of when
they're ready to take it on.
So I want to be--
we were meeting yesterday-- we
were meeting yesterday?-- with
a-- no, that was the night
before, sorry-- with a donor.
And the exciting thing was,
an American donor, but her
background is in cultural
anthropology.
So she hasn't been in
school in, with all
due respect, 30 years.
But she got it.
And so it's very touch and go.
But those issues, that fits with
what I'm talking about
with larger evaluation.
If those big changes are going
to be made, there's a whole
lot of men who have
to be involved.
There's a whole lot of parents
who have to be involved.
And sometimes it's looking for
that person who will stand up
and say, I actually did this.
So the story that I told at
the beginning of Zinat,
Shaheen went and educated her
parents and said, like, sort
of nicely, could you-- but
it's not me doing it.
It's the organization that I
fund calling on that father
and saying, your daughter is 17
and she's been in 3 abusive
relationships.
That can't be what you wish
for your daughter.
And of course, sometimes you
run into a brick wall.
Sorry, that's what
I have to do.
But sometimes, you'll find the
people are ready to make
social change.
AUDIENCE: How do you handle--
like, I'm from India.
And I know corruption is
so deep-seated that--
I mean, we see it every day
when you grow up there.
How do you handle corruption,
a, when you
invest with these groups?
But also even if you
educate women--
in the Delhi rape case, the
police were standing by and
doing nothing.
It's not just family support.
You need the government or
the law enforcers or--
even knowing your rights is not
enough if there's nobody
to enforce that you get it.
So can you speak to how
you deal with that?
RUTH MESSINGER: Right.
So the first half is easy.
Seriously, the first half of
your question, by and large
for the amounts that we invest
and the care with which we
determine the amount and the
fact that we're supporting
grassroots groups and we're not
going through governments,
we run into almost none of the
corruption that you are
correct exists.
And that's significant, because
I have a grants budget
I'm happy to say
of $15 million.
The United States probably
has a grant budget of
$15 million an hour.
But most of their budget,
including in places where they
really want to make a
difference, starts at the top
with government and ministries
and whatever.
And it doesn't get ever
to the people that
we're finding directly.
So I find that really because
of the incredible grassroots
and bottom-up work that we're
doing, we have only literally
in a handful of cases in the
last 14 years that I've been
there run into corruption by
heads of organizations.
And in most of those cases, I
actually wouldn't describe it
as corruption.
I would describe it as getting
too much Western money with
too many strings attached and
making it too hard for them to
figure out how to do it, so they
were running their own--
not with our money, which is
usually general operating
support, but then another group
would find them and fund
them to run a program.
And then a third group would
find them and fund them.
And they just didn't understand
what I have to
learn every day, which is the
mechanisms of being responsive
to donors and not--
OK.
So that part is easy.
The other part is like this
gigantic challenge.
And it's not so different from
the questions that you were
asking, like those changes are
only going to come-- and it's
hard to sort of say this-- but
when one of those empowered
women decides to become the
local panchayat or challenge
the local panchayat.
My favorite story was a town in
which for some reason the
Indian government decided--
this is like 10 years ago--
to bring television to some of
these rural communities.
And so there was like the notion
of find a community,
like a center in town, and
put the TV there, so
people can watch it.
And a group of women that we
were already funding to do
microfinance discovered that the
panchayat had taken-- this
is the local government officer,
for those of you who
aren't Indian--
who had taken the television and
put it in his own house.
So they organized and one
morning at 7:00 AM he opened
the door and there were
40 women sitting in
front of his house.
And he said, what are
you doing here?
And they said, we're staying
here until you move the
television.
So it's like when is that
going to happen?
And I want to say, I'm so
respectful of the work you do
here and the universes that
you've built, I wish
it was as easy as--
but that's the way the
change occurs.
I do have a donor who's a donor
of ours who is also on
his own-- we just manage the
money for him-- but investing
heavily in trying to change
corruption in the police
departments in rural Kenya
and not in India.
And I'm working with
him all the time.
And I like what he's doing and
I'm happy to move that money
for him, because it makes
my bank account larger.
But I think he and I would
be the first to agree.
Once you get to that level,
it's really difficult.
Are you sure you have
a good person?
And if you are-- and by
the way, this is an
issue that I have too.
You might have a good police
chief and I might have a great
head of an NGO, but then much is
dependent on them and their
strength and their staying
in place and their
not becoming corrupted.
So I think you gave
great examples.
And all I will say is I
particularly learned from
working with these sex workers,
they are fierce.
So I'll tell you a story.
We had a volunteer who went with
us to Uganda and worked
for a labor rights organization
in Uganda.
And he got to know a group which
was an organization of
sex workers.
So we were funding them mostly
to make sure that they had
good health care.
But they described to us and
then they described to this
young man, who was a lawyer by
training, that their problem
was the police.
The police would show up and
say, we know that you're
selling sex for money.
And we're not paying.
We just want the sex.
And they were both demanding it
for no money and they were
abusing them.
And they were being violent.
So it was exactly what the
women didn't want.
So this young lawyer
talked to them.
And he said, OK, look.
This is like a long shot.
I don't think this will work.
You'll never bring a criminal
case successfully against any
of those people, but because
of Ugandan law, we might be
able to bring a civil case.
So what I need you to do is,
when a police officer shows up
and does that, I can't stop them
from doing it, but if you
can get his name and his badge
number and just collect these
over the next few months, then
we'll bring a civil case.
So they said OK.
And then he didn't hear
from them at all.
So he thought it
hadn't worked.
So after like 2 and 1/2 months,
he called them.
And he said, I thought we were
going to collaborate in this
civil suit.
And they said, oh, our
problems are over.
And he said, what do you mean
your problems are over?
And they said, when the police
show up, we say, you know, we
have a camera.
You don't know where it is.
They said, we don't have a
camera but we tell them we
have a camera.
And we're writing down your
names and your badge numbers.
And we have a lawyer who's going
to sue you all and name
you in the local newspaper.
And they went away.
So this guy feels like he
solved the problems of
corruption in Uganda.
But I mean, that's the
kind of initiative.
And I mean, I'm very fortunate
to have this job.
But I keep hearing it come
up from the bottom.
And look, it's terrible.
I could tell you horrendous
problems.
One of the countries I was in in
the past year was Cambodia.
And in Cambodia, they pay
teachers so little that, first
of all, they don't come to work
so the school structure
isn't what it looks like.
And second of all, they
demand sexual
favors from their students.
Now I'm not going to be able
to stop that tomorrow.
But it's building a group that
just sort of stands up
someplace and says, enough.
We're not taking this anymore.
And we do know that those people
have been successful in
history, including for
sure in India.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Does
anyone who's on
the GVC have a question?
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a question?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It's very nice to
meet you, Ruth.
I get a lot of emails from
American Jewish World Service,
and I have two friends that are
actually in India, working
with the AJWS right now.
RUTH MESSINGER: Wonderful.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually leaving
for India tonight.
RUTH MESSINGER: All right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I'm very excited.
And one thing that I struggle
with a little bit is that
especially working at Google,
where we're very focused on
connecting people around the
world, and bringing Google
services to people around the
world because it unlocks
knowledge, which turns into
power and [INAUDIBLE]
information, I sometimes feel
that there's a concept of
well, these people in these
remote countries are so far
away from me.
What could I ever do?
I live in the United States.
And I know I'm lucky to have all
these things, but there's
not much I can do personally.
As I'm going on this trip, or
for anyone else that has an
upcoming trip to one of these
countries you're talking
about, what can you recommend
upon returning, actions that
we can take in just
our daily lives?
RUTH MESSINGER: OK.
Don't tell people how much I
paid you to ask this question
at this particular
point in time.
So I think there's
several things
that are really important.
One is really pay attention,
you yourself, I don't know
you, but to like what you're
seeing and how it impacts you,
because bringing back for those
people who didn't grow
up in another country or haven't
travelled, bringing
back the descriptions, you have
to be careful, because
some of it threatens just
to overwhelm people.
And then they think there's
nothing I can do.
But on the other hand, people
haven't seen the dimensions of
poverty, oppression, hunger that
you may see some of, that
you'll learn from your friends
who are over there.
So part of it is just sort of
coming back as a reporter as
to what you've seen.
But ideally, we're talking
about coming back as a
reporter of not only what you
saw in the problems, but what
you see as these change
agent organizations.
I mean, we run study
tours every year.
And part of the reason for that
is that I've learned that
I can talk a lot, and I do, and
tell stories, which I try
to do, but seeing it really
changes people's understanding
of the fact that solutions come
from the grassroots, of
the fact that relatively little
money that we're giving
to these organizations makes
dramatic change.
But then when you come
back, it's--
and I'll push a little bit--
it's to take on three roles.
One is educating your friends.
And since you're at Google,
you all have
this amazing network.
So it's literally do a blog.
If it's a great blog,
we'll publish it.
But do a blog.
Sort of say, here's
what I saw.
Here's what I learned.
Here are the kinds of groups
that I understand are making a
difference.
So it's community education.
Two is, of course I will
mention donations.
And I just want to
say carefully--
and this came up in an early
question, but pay attention.
There are groups that are
doing just spectacular
advertising to get you to give
them money and they have
terrible scores from the
rating agencies.
The rating agencies are
far from perfect.
They know that they are
They know that they don't
measure enough about impact,
just what your question was.
But they're rating for at
least decent financial
management.
And I have people all the time
who say, oh, well, if I were
going to give to you, I'd have
to stop giving to my favorite
charity, which is X. And I can
sometimes say, have you ever
looked up that charity?
They're like spending all their
money writing you for
more money.
And those are all rated.
So it's like to think about
giving and giving
thoughtfully.
And please don't think, which
you alluded to correctly,
don't think it's
just my money.
I can't do enough.
I can't make a difference.
Don't think this is
so overwhelming.
I mean, if I would say anything
to all of us as
Americans, as Google employees,
it's we don't have
the luxury of retreating
to being overwhelmed.
We actually each have the
capacity to make a difference.
Small amounts of money make
a big difference.
And the third thing that you
can do is get involved,
hopefully with us, but really
with anybody on advocacy.
The United States spends
our tax dollars doing
international development
work rather poorly.
They spend that money for
geopolitical purposes.
I'm in favor of that.
I would like us to have good
standing in the world.
I'd like us to have friends.
But it's not--
whatever they tell you, it's
unfortunately not money that's
usually going to help
poor people.
And so that's why in a sense
you need to look for
additional charities and
targeted dollars and need to
look at their ratings.
But it's also why you have to
work to change US policy.
So we would be happy--
we'll pass around a
piece of paper.
You can tell Anya if any of you
want to be on our website
or whatever, it's not painful.
You're all good at
communicating.
But right now, we need people
to be lobbying members of
Congress on this
budget change.
This is huge.
And I promise you that a change
in where food dollars
are going is not going to be
on the front pages of "The
Chronicle" or "The New York
Times" in the next month I
don't think.
I wish it were.
We actually get quoted
in these articles.
We got quoted in "The
Manchester Guardian"
yesterday, which is
like big deal.
But there's a lot of talk about
tax cuts and cuts to
entitlement programs.
And that's where the debate
is going to be.
But if the United States can
really under the State
Department spend money flexibly
to buy food from
local farmers, it could make a
huge difference in key parts
of the world.
So it's educate others, think
wisely about contributing.
And it's become an advocate
for change.
And I will tell you, because
it motivates me, a few
teachings, not surprisingly
right now these happen to be
Jewish teachings.
But they're pretty applicable
to the whole world.
So there's a famous social
justice oriented rabbi of the
20th century who said in a free
society where terrible
wrongs exist, some are guilty,
but all are responsible.
And then there's a long ago
Jewish teaching that says you
are not required to complete the
task, but you can't refuse
to participate.
So those are thoughts I
would leave with you.
And thank you for the great
opportunity and the question.
AUDIENCE: If you could talk
about the disaster relief work
that you do, and especially
how do you find those
grassroots organizations in
places that you've never
worked in before and to do it
quickly so that it actually
has an impact?
RUTH MESSINGER: It's
a perfect question.
We actually don't.
We will increasingly going
forward, strategically as a
lesson we've learned over the
last 15 years, we will target
our disaster--
our visibility after a disaster
will be targeted to
the extent that it's a country
in which we already work.
That doesn't mean we'll refuse,
because disasters
because of media and because
of sad stories and drama,
disasters are one of the few
issues that get covered in the
American press.
And so it's one of the times for
us to capture new donors.
So God forbid if there was a
disaster tomorrow in a country
in which we've never worked, we
would put ourselves on the
Google lists, on "The New
York Times" list.
But we would also strategize
within 36 hours, because
that's about the window that we
have, as to, OK, if we get
a lot of money for this
disaster, exactly what are we
going to do, because it's
not a country in
which we've done work?
And the most likely answer is we
partner with some people or
we tell people, if you want to
feed people tomorrow, actually
don't send the money to us.
Because it's going to take us
two months to figure out.
That's on the first hand.
On the other hand, countries
where we have worked, where we
know grassroots groups, I'm
just going to say right up
front, we are infinitely better
placed to do your
relief money, because the money
will actually get to the
people in need almost
immediately.
And it won't all be spent at
once, because in Haiti the
story is not just what did
people need right away.
Haiti's a country that fed its
entire population on its own,
off of its own land
50 years ago.
And it's now totally dependent
on expensive imports.
And the big danger after
something like the earthquake
is that it will only
make that worse.
The more food aid we bring in,
the lower the options for
Haitian farmers.
And so we're really
pretty smart.
We received $6.5 million
after the earthquake.
And we didn't tell every $10
donor, but we told every
decent sized donor, this is a
five year plan for investment
in protecting women and
girls and agricultural
sustainability in Haiti.
And if you want to spend it
tomorrow, give it to someone
else, but it won't
be as useful.
We had eight project partner
organizations in Haiti at the
time of the earthquake, two that
we had funded previously.
We now have 41, because they
lead us to others.
[APPLAUSE]
RUTH MESSINGER: Oh, I forgot
to say first of all that we
advertise our trips on our
website, which is ajws.org.
And second of all, despite my
evident advanced age, I want
you all to know that I tweet.